President Putin meeting for tea with the
mothers of Russian servicemen up close
and personal a chance for an exchange of
views
[Music]
he has to do it though because of videos
like these
off we were lied to we had no training
says this man his group mobilized from
around Moscow thrown into battle at
machiaveka in eastern Ukraine
endless videos too of mothers and wives
demanding the president listen and give
their men the weapons and the training
they need
these women came to Moscow last weekend
to bring a list of Demands to officials
they've been tailed ever since people
who slink off hoods up when the women
challenge them but the group's social
media feed has picked up quite a
following mothers from all across the
country voicing their support
systems
as long though as it looks like the
Kremlin is paying attention at a forum
this week in Moscow to an audience of
young Cadets and officers in training
tributes paid to the mothers of those
fighting and lost in Ukraine
umarova's husband and son are both at
the front
what would you say to Ukrainian mothers
who are in your positions
[Music]
foreign that is something of course the
Kremlin won't promise but it knows very
well that the best way to head off this
viral spread of complaints from the
relatives is to embrace it say that it's
listening even if it's not
mothers had some sway during the Chechen
War but they won't convince the Kremlin
to change course says Valentina
melnikova who's headed up the committee
of soldiers mothers since Soviet times
despite the horrific casualties there
will always be fresh blood waiting in
the wings trained to believe that dying
for the motherland is a true and Noble
cause whatever course of action the
motherland has decided to take
dynamagne Sky News Moscow